oh yeah you see Chippendale dancers or
me when I used to do dancing you know
they'll pull it a couple times and
stretch it you pull and stretch it then
let go all Chippendale dancers do that
they don't just go to stage and pull up
and stuff it'll be a noodle they'll be
like [ __ ] yes now you're dancing Yuna
kidding me you know I'm originally from
New York Bayside Queens New York where I
got my degree I got my bachelor's in
education
bachelor's in theater I taught theater
at the Ventura Theatre School and from
New Brunswick New Jersey and then I
learned I got my masters in special ed
while I was teaching mentally
handicapped I did it so many years ago
they didn't call it autism they called
it childhood schizophrenia showed me how
back in hatred I just started teaching
in 1977
oh no 70 76 77 yes my mom I was going to
raise my mom and dad she she developed
Parkinson's disease so she was a bit
hard to work with deal with it was tough
and we all loved it and we do our thing
you know
Parkinson's isn't really shorten your
life it just makes it not a great life
you know so we all you know we still got
along as a family my dad held it
together he's around today he drives a
car he's a hundred and three years old
my dad lives in it like Nashville
Tennessee my brother is it heads up a
huge corporation he's uh works for them
and he was covered I have a cousin my
female cousin who I helped to get her
first job as a waitress up in the
Catskill Mountains a lot of Jews went up
there for fresh air you know and so she
works for the government very
high-ranking we're all very proud she
went to Stanford so I got and my mom was
a spy during World War two cuz she was
you know behind enemy lines a couple of
times so I'm a dad doped
towers in the Philippines they try to
you know keep it pro-american not so
Japanese you know that's a great family
very bit right hard-working intelligent
proud to call herself a Jeremy that's
really my name the job market was so
hard difficult for you know to get work
because everybody wants to do it in New
York Los Angeles Florida Chicago people
you know the driving a taxi and first
thing he says well I'm driving a cab
however I'm actually an actor was
actually a writer I'm actually a
songwriter you know I wrote that yeah
everyone you know wants to be a
performer so that it was a horribly
difficult job market so I kind of
settled you know I met a guy named Joe
Sarno who was directing regular you know
movies we hung out with shad and he goes
listen I got some weird news for you I
saw the the pictures I didn't Playgirl
magazine which I did John Ritter was on
the cover which I'll tell you later on
how coincidental that is but he wasn't
nude or anything but he was skimpy you
know bathing suit with Three's Company
was hot so John Ritter
he's gonna cover I was inside the
magazine and years later me and John
both suffered you know heart problems
you know the aortic you know heart
problems
vascular heart problems and we both had
an aortic dissection at the same time in
mid Kaiser knee at cedars-sinai he
passed away he didn't make it I did you
know and I'm here to talk about it so
one of the very few people actually have
survived you know aortic dissection and
in fact CNN called me a badass
for driving myself to the hospital I was
driving myself to the hospital so anyway
so so high gradient so I was doing
theater went to Joe Joe said I'll put
you in a movie but my films are no long
all right it I'm shooting porn and he
was actually almost a legendary director
you know for me much as Sweden needs to
shoot he was very well known very well
respected I said to Joe maybe he'll do
it then he goes well if you can do it I
asked my friends and family what they
thought and at that time I was doing I
was teaching mentally challenged kids I
was doing theater on fetch aha in New
York and then I got this option to make
some money because he met dick when
you're trying to be an actor and so I
gave it a shot
asked my family what they think and I
said you know just kind of sleazy doing
porn but then again I'm sleazy maybe
it's a perfect match so I went to did it
I was able to do it people saw that I
had to have larger-than-average
schmeckel so I took out the schmeckle
right out of the pants balls-deep you
know and there you have your first that
was 1978 1977 we shot it 1978 they were
adding more scenes and then also Denis
and John Ritter had our problem and
they're crazy and then he is later
you know John had a bigger problem and
died Amyas back his wife and actress
suit you know because there were
mistakes made supposedly he was not he
was being held under observation my
doctors at UCLA and at cedars-sinai said
there's no observation for you Ron we
want to bring you right into operation
right now you're looking you're alive
how long's the operation 10 hours huh
how long am I gonna be recuperating a
month I had plans tomorrow not anymore
I had a wedding in that anymore they
have it
cute little Indian guy kept me alive
everyone said he saved my life he
wouldn't let me go which I love the guy
for it I knew I needed a second
operation I was bleeding internally but
some doctors will go if he on that
because are you gonna survive or not he
was not gonna let me go
you know this guy is gold others have
seen him since I referred him
Amir Shah and my cardiologist Ernst
Schwartz
so the two guys the business has changed
like you would believe I thought he was
changing a lot when it went from film to
video to VHS Betamax the internet to
interact in interactivity to virtual
reality you know - ridiculous dialogue
way from okay who ordered the large
sausage how come you don't have the
money to pay for it
- other scenes where amateur you know
it's like you know what you're gonna do
when they come for you you know you
think you look out the window here of
your home and go hey look if you can
sink cops we just saw on television some
[ __ ] that is the same cop said you know
so it became more like goofy you know I
just those crazy dialogue scenes then it
got classy feels like cafe flesh
roommates Chuck Vincent Anthony Spinelli
some famous directors like Wes Craven
who did nightmare odometry Elm Street
you know Adelson John elbows and I think
did either softcore hardcore it was
becoming almost almost publicly
acceptable to do this because it just
was acceptable maybe made a satire the
judge wouldn't allow they prosecuted
some of these porn films and the judge
you know in New York try to let some of
it go and trying to remind people this
is freedom of speech these are
performers and it was a very
touch-and-go situation they eventually
beat it I think Irene is Linda Lovelace
you know and there you have it
porn was kind of born and then it went
to like I said more highly advanced
science they started going to
interactivity and now like I said
virtual reality and now and then the
internet now a large part of the
business is can girls they look around
the computer hi Bob
look this girl pretty this is me we hope
you win the award tonight you know
that's a large part of the business now
it's the cam girls are a large part of
the biz and before they were on and the
public seems to like it got male talent
does not like it
you know guys in foreign because not a
lot of work for them anymore now it's
just you and the consumer hi Bob so I
pull down my panties you know yeah
please you know how's that for a nasty
voice yes pull them all the way down
good come over here and sit right on my
face nobody argues that that's worldwide
when I went to Europe when I was
shooting films in Italy Remini which
hyoni feelin's Florence and Roma with
Rocco chilena and all these people you
know I worked on internationally and I
did great with it
Mario Soleri Mario Altieri Mario Pollock
Roe Carlos Kiki
choo-choo-choo Lena became the only or
the first we'll see what happens now
diplomat to actually attain office as a
porn star
you know Kitsch Lena was Hungarian the
lowness taller as a real name and she
liked it there's no not on Jeremy and so
we did a couple scenes together and I
admired the fact that in Italy the
Parliament voted in a porn star and she
has that title for life not the one porn
star that being a diplomat that was too
cool and then woke up the next morning
joking it was a joke that kidding
Guiseppe she was on the radio huh
some porn stars just gotta to the
Parliament it I voted for her said
everybody else what [ __ ] well me you
know that's kind of she became the only
and then she got not allowed to come
into America sandy to discuss this
before is interesting because she was
trying to make a deal with terrorists
that America doesn't do that she made
out an initial she gave a big speech
where she said that if Saddam Hussein
when he had those captive Americans
because if you let them go if she'll
have had Saddam was saying well let the
girls go and guys she'll have sex with
him American government took it a little
too serious and banned it'll never
coming into America so she will came in
through Canada because she had a child
she had a son and she had a custody
battle Jeff Koons very famous artist and
out of New York say hey you know what is
you know he won the right to have
custody she won the right to have
custody somebody's got to give up
something personality traits finding the
humor and anything and everything
nothing can't be too funny or unfunny
you know it's a allowing yourself to
still make a fool of yourself and then
shine right afterwards you know yeah I
mean I wouldn't mind I love kids I used
to be a school teacher
and I I I would be a great dad but not a
great husband my beings are probably the
swinging lifestyle you know
a lot of them are especially in our
business are you I do the other girl and
probably mystery is narrow but but I am
totally accept and respect people's
choices
but should I'd like the porn actors I
talked to it all said most of them said
you kind of need to stick with somebody
in the industry it already had a
successful relationship was it a guy or
girl well I wouldn't say this totally
true they heard the expression opposites
can attract yeah you know it's the way
it certainly does give you an added
boost I think you know probably all and
you know it makes it yeah you have a
more about understanding you don't you
don't sweat the small stuff you know
like you accept the fact that maybe
we're here to be emotionally monogamous
travel together hold hands look at the
scenery
under the Grand Canyon and physically
non-monogamous you know because it's
easier to do that it's very hard yeah I
mean ick you know I've been I had my
name on a swing club was called Ron
Jeremy's club see so in Portland Oregon
they did good did real good and I saw
how people weren't it was really a good
lesson that you know if you can get past
this the jealousy you can have a good
time you know it doesn't mean you have
to play hide the bacon and shoot the
sherbert drain the main vein and squeeze
the weasel you don't have to do that you
can just simply be with your own wife
your own husband and watch other people
and that's a turn-on we're gonna look
super mental there you go if you get
into that lifestyle it can be a lot of
fun you know you get a you know and do
it we then share it with a person you
care about and you didn't let it get too
far you just don't even a physical fun
then go back together again for another
few months few years whatever you feel
the itch to be with some other flesh
doesn't detract from the romance people
always afraid of that it's not and if
you are afraid of that do something
where it's too far to get to like Maui
Hawaii our Key West Florida if you do
things down there you know you got as
much to worry about because it's too big
a deal to go to those exotic
Haitians so you and your wife or you and
your girlfriend whatever can this enjoy
a nice romance what is about the act of
sex then it pushes people's money so
many people get worked up over whether
it's meaning in a bad way
yeah like shame or there's connected
with it sometimes and there's all kind
of weird it's it's a shame because you
shouldn't get worked up although but
it's a fun thing I mean I like that
hustling had a very nice slogan it was
called relax it's just sex
I like that yeah and it's true making
too big a deal about it just have fun
you want to do something do it you don't
don't
and what's funny to is that they said
you know you can get hard you know God
knows why and Bill Marvel had a great
expression he said you're not gonna get
hurt watching porn nobody ever died
watching porn unless they got too close
to the VCR and got electrocuted
otherwise you know and it it's true I
mean they're they when I debate the xxx
Church kind of Crisco of Craig gross
even all over the world debating and I
made it a point to say that you know
which has done more to kill people
religion or adult movies everything we
do here is good you must be recognized
when you're on the public right yes and
you have beautiful like fans or talk to
you
yes we actually get Hey Dude what so so
like is Christy cackling will I got
natural boobies or hey you guys got to
take those tests you got to do that did
you have to do gate found this before
good strength fellows in those are some
of the ones the apparents know what
you're doing it's just - no - doing your
cousin best friends they know they're
what you're doing so I do it and fall
into your lap because you're ron jeremy
well I said I wish they would more often
but yes I get them some of that once in
a while how many let's see
whatever guys he asked me that I've
raised funny answer I always say
including your mom I had one too but
that but around 3,600 but me and I do
talk about it my comedy actor me and
gene Simmons were asked that question by
Barbara Walters on two separate
occasions you know I said look this is
gene Simmons he gets girls that looked
like his Playboy Playmate Shannon Tweed
we married me but I'm not working I get
girls that look like gene Simmons
[Music]
that's not her stroke of course not
that's it that's a fair answer buddy
about 30 about 336 3,600 women the
industry Omega
for me people think that we're calling
the schoolyards looking for girls they
want to get in the business come on not
like that at all now let's grow up can
girls because who are you know working
you know and some as escorts some
topless clubs and news clubs you know so
it's like in the old volcano they get
the ads in the paper and they electric
models are just marks big large himself
these guys get the phone calls for the
work and then the girl comes in does it
interfere like anything else you know
they the people who really hate the
industry think that it doesn't want do
that that you know that the person is
like soliciting you they're not there
are a lot of girls who want to do this
and now on the cam girls we're just you
and the consumer you know the guy on it
it's all different building it really is
just a girl and the fan so that's why a
lot of adult film actors are not working
anymore a lot of my friends are not too
important anymore because this isn't the
work there was a woman and I think North
Carolina backfired because she was
discovered as a porn star look it's
gonna happen it you gotta you know think
of a career being a schoolteacher don't
do adult films today you know so that's
happened with an have there's a been
discrimination sure sure
you know there are the wrong woman who
had raw deal man that is often what
women yes but what are the downsides
well what I just said it was positive
and good and it feels good it's fun to
do and the same logic works against you
as well you know because if you're a
porn star and your wife really believes
our girlfriend believes that for love or
money that's it you're gonna play around
for a lover money if it's a brothel and
I'm gonna invest on all the guy or
something or it's gonna I'm helping her
in the breadwinning then I'm gonna earn
us a living you know and you can kick in
and work at the gas station where you
were before and this way we'll all have
fun you know so sometimes you know that
which makes porn fun and you're tough
enough to take it because your wife or
girlfriend loves you they're just gonna
watch some other couple you know so the
good is it works and I've seen it work
really well the bad is it might not work
you know Hey Dude yep that's my girl
you're at a swing club put a Sun on your
forehead nine and three-quarter inches I
love that one they're the longest Margie
Alice Tanya hi Margie four years Alice
four years I was in high school at the
time I was four years Tanya I was really
into college and then going into porn I
was like two years there's four years
four years two years and then Venice and
I were more like friends from the very
beginning Venice and then Natalie French
for 15 years
best friends shares the bunch of
adorable children and I'm uncle Ron
whenever I show up you know the car
pulls up to where they're living and in
the south and the girls will come
running out of the house uncle rod uncle
Juan how do you beat that
as kind of things I like people would
expect I like incredibly interesting
stories from your illustrious career
right sure here a story or two I'm on
the come in Majorca Spain oh he had done
some stuff in Spain and now I'm shooting
in Majorca on the ocean
I took boning pills which John Leslie
told me to take and it was a really well
star cast not show Vidal from Spain
Rocco from Italy Church Alina monopod
see a lot of the big European stars were
on a boat everybody throw up I did not
because it John Leslie saved me
you know these pills that really work
and then but the girl would be bent over
the edge of the boat and rather than
blowing me she's blowing chunks and so
then I told the director when we were
gonna do this and Mario Soleri with a
gun insulin beautiful girl goes look
these girls are gonna have sex with Iran
we need to get the shots they're
throwing up we can all deal with it
girls it's okay so I think it's actually
with two girls and while they were
shooting we they show up the action they
shot the hardcore you know right there
uncircumcised dicks a lot of Italian
boys and they didn't hand up and down
this far and you see hardcore action
right and then when they got to shore
the nice thing about seasickness is it
goes away once you're in another Shore
so we get to the shore everyone felt
great I was the only one who do not get
ill anyway but Carolyn got sick makeup
artist got sick
the chef got sick and I never did so
then now they shot me and the girl or
their faces against the sky and going
the same dialogue Oh baby oh yeah oh and
so uh that was a cup shot
here's his sperm in the throat thank you
play so then uh so we'll get back to
shore we shot the footage we needed and
just didn't show the action because
during that portion there was vomit so
worked out fine I said to this very day
when you see that scene you can know
that while the scene was being shot
people everybody was vomiting and when I
was doing the make-believe like oh yeah
oh baby oh yeah that was that was all
fake interesting huh imagine a
moviemaking career I guess we don't do
that sometimes cuz like I was going for
her mainstream for there I didn't choose
porn you know I wanted to do I feel yeah
it was Joe Sarno and he again a very
well-known filmmaker I like the quality
but it was good people liked his stuff
and that's where it all began
you know him and guy named Dylan Ross
brought me onto various stats to see how
it goes Cintron what do you say
yeah you have it I said I'll give it a
try
your personality you don't take things
seriously you look at everything grain
assault yeah but you know I don't want
to be good put on a good show I mean you
really have you really want to it have
to you know yeah people think oh it's
just porn just pull my ass it's selling
remember I was there during the heyday
they called it the Golden Ears people
there was out there were thousands of
tapes TVs VHS is internet all coming up
coming along being born you gotta take
it seriously if you're gonna you want to
become a porn star you can't just hope
they take it like any other acting job
get up on time if it's a girl have your
hair in curlers go to the set on time I
mean your porn film back in the 70s and
80s it was just like a regular movie
that was the low-budget it was like a
Troma film or it was like Trey Parker
matt stone like a South Park project
they don't believe in unions or now they
do but they were doing low-budget B
movies with a real funny twist that was
hysterically funny I worked for them I
was one of the leads in our gasma I also
had to lead a lead in all major part and
Boondock Saints huge film
the will of the foe plays an FBI agent
was gay his solves crimes you know so
I've got about a hundred and some-odd a
regular movies oh yeah I have the
world's record most music videos
nobody's even close matt LeBlanc did 11
I did 56 music videos I'd say when I was
uh have making any great accomplishments
I wrote a book that was a New York Times
bestseller I did a rap song and I can't
rap with a [ __ ] but I did good at it and
it was both flick of the week DJ polo
ice-t simek's a lot grandpa Munster Lynn
Redgrave had a lot of stars in it they
were hoping that I'd go on to better
stuff I told them it's only a means to
an end you know so I said oh that's the
means to an end
I didn't make a ton because they think
that were that we're millionaires we're
never a thousand ends you know the girls
will make a couple of grand I'll make a
couple of grand once in a while
otherwise we'll be maybe a few hundred
if it's a gang scene or a bunch of guys
one girl a bunch of girls one guys
depends on the scene you know but it's
not what people think I mean I looked at
the internet I saw the figures they gave
me and Jessica chained like great
Christie Canyon was in there I thought
they were writing no way off base there
saying all these people that Elaine is
no they're not not even close so you
don't only get always get the true the
true answer you know and some of this
stuff yeah we don't make what people
think we do
oh you bastard oh come on I'm 66 great
why you something you still look great
you're still working well thank you for
that and I am slower doing scenes I
didn't stop send people thought I
stopped nice low work yeah
too much fun to quit I have the world's
record for inque but 33,500 that I did a
rap song called sexy and I know it I was
in it you see me in three spots and went
on to become 150 million hits a quarter
or half a billion hits on sexy and I
know it I I had about a thousand know
about a half a billion people saw me
sing good night it was all auld lang
syne it's funny this is definitely
appreciate I this was on CNN on the
Harrison Cooper show remember him say he
might heaven grant Kathy Griffin invited
me on the show it's gotta be 14 seconds
so I did it 42 14 seconds salute auld
lang syne right on target my friend a
terrific and shot it and I was seen by
half a billion people on HBO and
hopefully is something like this two
seconds
[Music]
thank you you all see me on piano you
wanna see me on violin a lot of the
big-name rock stars have said that I'm
as good as they are violin harmonica and
piano if you look at the sheet rock song
called cowboy want to be a cowboy baby
sees on the piano on that song cowboy
and I play to the Celtic band in Ireland
so yeah I've been a good lot of fun I've
got a lot of fun things it's been great
venture isn't sure your personalities is
very easygoing all thanking life and
charming I think that's all yeah thank
you
ease that you could be really troubling
career thing is some people go of course
some people don't survive and thrive but
you have what's sad look actresses and
actors have problems all over Hollywood
they even needs to say that Alan Alda is
so nice and so friendly and has so few
scandals he couldn't find a dog mean
enough to bite him because he was known
for being then real sweet a good guy
right we've never cheated on his wife
Alice Cooper never cheated on his wife I
mean there's certain things they say
Howard Stern ever cheated on his wife
now is that true or false who knows what
it's funny because you know
point is what is very accurate I'd say
you get into the business I have to tell
that to kids I was teaching about you
know when you want to continue with a
job and try a different one
you know I say that you know if you come
into a business with the level head and
you're professional you're on time I
don't care if you're a dishwasher okay
if you're cleaning fire hydrants or a
porn star you know if you keep your head
level you take yourself professionally
take it serious you can have fun in fact
you should but if you can do that then
you will do well because you just you
know you're allowing yourself not to be
taken too seriously because of this
particular career but you'll have fun
and you'll make money and you know
that's a career like anybody else nice
questions very well designed